[Applaus]
[Musik]
es geschieht dort wo es niemand erwartet
dann wenn niemand damit rechnet aus
Gründen die niemand kennt und wer doch
etwas weiß der schweigt es sind
ungelöste Mordfälle die die Angehörigen
in Schmerz und Trauer stürzen und die
Ermittler ratlos zurücklassen wir haben
wirklich vom Anfang bis zum Schluss
praktisch keine Spuren praktisch kann ja
wirklich so sein
aber es bringt nicht nur stark lieben
und der profika das mit erfinden
t
zu irgendetwas
[Musik]
wieso musste Patricia Wilhelm am 27
februar 2004 sterben
wer ist die Person die zweimal am 15
dezember 2010 und am genau gleichen Tag
fünf Jahre später seine DNA am Tatort
zweier Morde hinterließ
wer brachte am 6 juni 1976 in Seewen
fünf Menschen um es ist seit jeher das
Schweigen des Wissenden das dem
Ermittler langsam jede Hoffnung raubt 7
juni 76 die Tagesschau meldet eines der
größten Verbrechen der Schweizer
Kriminalgeschichte am Morgen des 6 juni
1976 wollte die Tochter des Besitzers
dieses Wochenende Hauses ihre Eltern
besuchen sie fand Patronenhülsen und
Blutspuren und alarmierte die Polizei
den eintreffenden Beamten bot sich ein
Bild des Grauens sie standen vor fünf
blutüberströmten Leichen
älterer Menschen
die Gerichtsreporterin Christine Brandt
hat sich in ihrer Arbeit mit zahlreichen
ungelösten Mordfällen befasst
den mordfallsäge
in der Schweiz und es ist der
klar geworden
aus Sachbearbeiter
[Musik]
und dann
soll die Mittagessen
46 Jahre nach diesem fünffach-mord
besucht Yaki den Tatort noch immer nagt
an ihm dass er den Fall nie ganz lösen
konnte
fast ein halbes Jahrhundert nach dem
Blutbad von Seewen bleiben Fragen offen
fünf Menschen starben an jenem
Pfingstsamstag die Tochter des Ehepaares
hatte die Leichen entdeckt
als Jacke und seine Leute eintrafen
wurde ihnen das Ausmaß erst richtig
bewusst
[Musik]
um
rot gesehen
und Frau die angeheiratete Frau Sieger
ist ich im depper
wachsene Menschen erschossen an einem
Waldrand bei Seelen
ein Verbrechen von noch nie da gewesenem
Ausmaß in der Schweiz
im Gasthof Sonne errichtete die Kripo
Solothurn kurz nach der Tat einen
Kommandoposten 20 Beamte gehen hier
täglich ihrer verschwiegenen Tätigkeit
nach man sieht sie kommen und gehen von
ihrer Arbeiter fährt man nichts Erfolge
und Misserfolge im Fortgang ihrer
Ermittlungstätigkeit müssen der
Öffentlichkeit bis zur endgültigen
Aufklärung des Verbrechens vorenthalten
werden ein erster Befund
des Gerichtsmedizin des Landes dahin
das mindestens vier von den fünf
Personen
in freien erschossen worden sind
alle Leichen weisen Kopfschüsse auf
bis zum heutigen Tag weiß niemand warum
das Ehepaar Elsa und Eugen Sigrist
Eugens Schwester Anna westhäuser Sigrist
sowie deren Söhne Emanuel und Max
westhäuser sterben mussten
die Polizei verfolgte in den Wochen und
Monaten danach jede Spur gegenüber 9000
Hinweisen nach vergeblich die Tat blieb
ungeklärt obwohl die Polizei einen
größeren Aufwand Betrieb als bei jedem
Verbrechen zuvor es schien keine Zeugen
zu geben
[Musik]
seit dem 6 juni sind die wenigen
vorhandenen Spuren gesichert die Kripo
hat mich nur die Kugeln ins ballistische
Labor geschickt man hat sogar das ganze
Ferienhaus der Opfer abtransportiert
hunderte von ermittlungs- und
fahndungsreporten stapeln sich
inzwischen im Kommando Posten von Seven
Patrone wir sind wirklich
Spezial und dann haben wir aber
im Film gesehen
doch wer besaß zu dieser Zeit eine
Winchester
nur über die Antwort auf diese Frage
würde die Polizei den Täter finden
orientiert
in jeweilige Kanton sollt
das ist sowas sieht das letzte Mal ist
da es sich um einen Mord an mehreren
Familienmitgliedern handelte suchte die
Polizei zu Beginn im nächsten Umfeld der
Opfer
Robert Sigrist der Sohn von Elsa und
Eugen Sigrist wurde verdächtigt und
verhaftet
Frau verhaftet hat Polizeibeamten
sehr befragt oder wir wollen uns und
salibio gerade noch abklären
Robert Sigrist hier rechts neben seinem
getöteten Cousin Manuel stand also
plötzlich unter Verdacht seine Eltern
und Verwandten getötet zu haben
und das dekodiert
der Verdacht erhärtete sich nicht Robert
sie Christ wurde freigelassen und noch
immer fehlte das Motiv für die Tat
für mich ist es klare familienmodus
ganze Familie ausgelöscht worden die
Familie aber es ist natürlich
mehrfachmord für mich ist
für mich
das einsames
laufen
möglichst viel Menschen
persönlich bringen aber was genau das
ist das motiviert das ist mir klar wurde
eröffnet 1976 natürlich
die Polizisten noch ganz ganz anders
müssen
und zwar nachträglich wenn man die als
erwartet aufbewahrt also vielleicht
wenn man das nicht aufbewahrt fällt mir
das auch nachträglich
wieder Spurenmaterial vorhanden
die Schweiz hat bei Tötungsdelikten eine
sehr hohe Aufklärungsrate 9 von 10
Fällen werden gelöst und doch gibt es
immer wieder solche die unlösbar
scheinen
in Zürich ereignete sich am 15 dezember
2010 ein Mordfall den die Polizei bis
heute nicht aufklären konnte dabei
schien der Täter mit den Behörden einen
makabri-spiel zu spielen
rein zufällig begleitete an jedem Abend
ein Team des Schweizer Fernsehens SRF
den Staatsanwalt Matthias steinbach
Zürich Seefeld Mitte Dezember
das ruhige Wohnquartier ist Schauplatz
eines brutalen Verbrechens geworden die
Polizei hat bereits eine mobile
Einsatzzentrale aufgestellt
Matthias Stammbach ist als
diensthabender Staatsanwalt aufgeboten
worden
fünfzehnte dezember 2012 wie die frühen
Abend
oder so und dann ist Telefon hoch
ja das muss gerade in Zürich alt und
dann Gabler
die Staatsanwaltschaft
Polizeibeamte Rechtsmediziner im Moment
tappen noch alle im Dunkeln
jetzt geht es darum alle auf den
gleichen Wissensstand zu bringen
und man ist natürlich nervös man ist
auch gespannt Adrenalin all das und dann
zusammen und möchte voll konzentriert
das
[Musik]
Opfer eine Psychotherapeutin entdeckt
hatte sie ein Patient der bei ihr einen
Termin vereinbart hatte
[Musik]
ist gemacht worden
okay wenn dann zu öffnen
obwohl der Täter Spuren hinterlassen
hatte obwohl die Polizei schnell vor Ort
war und akribisch arbeitete
obwohl im Anschluss erstmals in der
Schweiz massende Ina Tests durchgeführt
wurden gelang es nicht den Täter zu
ermitteln es gab keine entscheidenden
Hinweise keine Zeugen
[Musik]
Blanche waton weiß wie es sich anfühlt
Angehörige in einem ungeklärten Mordfall
zu verlieren die große Leidenschaft der
französisch-schweizerischen
doppelbürgerin sind Trabrennen sie wurde
ihr von Gerda K und Josh s weitergegeben
die beiden waren zwar nicht leibliche
Verwandte für Blanche aber waren sie wie
Großeltern
[Musik]
für mich
das Personen wo kann ich Ihnen also wenn
ihr das Problem her oder irgendein
bisschen
und das sind eigentlich
verbrachte die ersten zehn Jahre ihres
Lebens auf George und Gerdas
Pferdegestüt im Elsass
[Musik]
ein paar Jahre später als George und
Gerda wieder in der Schweiz lebten
wurden sie Opfer eines rätselhaften
Mordes
Anzeichen dafür hatte es keine gegeben
[Musik]
es Telefon 24
das pensionierte Ehepaar war in Laupen
im Kanton Bern ermordet worden wieder
war es kurz vor Weihnachten wieder
fehlte ein Motiv
und es ist für unsere
Untergangs keine Antwort gegeben
dass der Mord auf den Tag genau fünf
Jahre nach dem Mord im Zürcher Seefeld
geschah schien reiner Zufall
der Fall Analytiker Hans-peter Meister
war damals bei diesem Verbrechen vor Ort
im Einsatz sieben Jahre danach kehrt er
zurück an den Tatort in einer alte
Käserei in der die Mordopfer wohnten
der heutige Besitzer hat Meister den
Zutritt ins Gebäude erlaubt im Wohnraum
erinnert heute nichts mehr an die
damaligen Vorkommnisse
genau hier wurden George S und Gerda K
am 15 dezember 2015 mutmaßlich mit einem
Bein erschlagen
ich sage jetzt hoch ist hier wenn das
noch die gleiche ist sag ich mal dann
wird das jetzt Situation gesehen dass
das hier
was drinnen passiert ist oder was es vor
einer gesehen und jetzt gut die wo das
nicht wissen dürfen
der Fall konnte nicht gelöst werden
keine Hinweise keine Zeugenaussagen die
Polizei musste sich mit den vielen
scheinbar unbrauchbaren Spuren begnügen
die sie am Tatort sichergestellt hatte
doch dann machten die Ermittler eine
überraschende Entdeckung
bei der DNA-Analyse im Labor fanden sie
eine Übereinstimmung mit der DNA aus
einem früheren Fall nicht aus
irgendeinem Fall sondern aus jedem im
Zürcher Seefeld der sich fünf Jahre vor
diesem hier ereignet hatte
das konnte nichts anderes heißen als das
ist der gleiche Täter war
[Musik]
ich
überrollt
und dann bin ich sehr nervös worden
es geht um zweideutigste
Therapeutin ihre Praxis und im Badener
Seeland ist Ehepaar besichtigen
zwei Jungen schädliche Nötigste
welches Geheimnis bergen dieses Haus im
ländlichen Laupen in Bern und diese
Praxis im Zürcher Seefeld
wer schweigt obwohl er mehr weiß
wie faszinierte dein Volk dass man
einfach
aber wie findest du einfach nie Probleme
betrachtet weil es ist denn nicht also
sag jetzt mal wenn man sexuelles Motiv
hatte das wüsste mir das war bekannt
wenn man es finanzielles Motiv hatte
konkret also sagen wir mal klassisch
die innerhalb Zimmer Wohnung immer mehr
Familie Hauser Praxis darstellt
finanziell der warte ich kenne 2000
Franken genommen
nicht
erkennenswert dass da irgendetwas wohnt
wo wirklich Geld dann gehen wir heiraten
bzw
Restaurants zwischen Opfer und
personenkonfliktfelder wurden zu führen
in der ersten Linie
hat der mittig nicht ergehen und das
heißt mehr rein statistisch gesehen wenn
man 95% faune der liegt mit der
Beziehung oder artbeziehung Prozent
zweimal hatte der Mörder am 15 Dezember
getötet
2010 und 2015
mit ungutem Gefühl erwarteten Ermittler
in der ganzen Schweiz den 15 dezember
2020 doch nichts geschah
was bleibt ist die unheimliche
Erkenntnis eines jeden Ermittlers
also das wüste drum dass da
ein Mensch
duschen ist wo für Dritte verantwortlich
gemacht wird das ist bei mir einmalig
und ich glaube das geht da wenige
Staatsverwaltung Staatsanwalt oder so
erlaubt hat dass man weiter schafft ohne
[Musik]
das Mordfälle nur selten ungelöst
bleiben mag für die Ermittler ein Trost
sein nicht aber für die betroffenen
Angehörigen
[Musik]
befinden und das kann man das abklären
wenn es heute mit allen technischen
Möglichkeiten nicht gelingt Mordfälle zu
klären wie groß oder klein ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach 46 Jahren zu
erfahren wer 1976 in Seewen Elsa und
Eugen Sigrist getötet hat
[Musik]
und wer am selben Tag auch Anna
westhäuser und ihre Söhne Max und
Emmanuel kaltblütig erschossen
[Musik]
Fallanalytiker Hans-peter Meister hat
sich auch mit diesem Tötungsdelikt
befasst aufgrund der gesicherten Spuren
vor Ort und Aufzeichnungen aus jener
Zeit versuchte den fünffach-mord zu
rekonstruieren
und was er noch macht hat ist bevor
gegangen ist im Prinzip der grössere
Blut lachen
nach seiner Theorie wurde zuerst Elsa
Sigrist danach ihr Ehemann Eugen
erschossen
dann wartete der Täter auf seine
nächsten drei Opfer
hey Paul vom vorgeher wird dann aber
die andere
gestanden egal
bleibt der Max wird jetzt mit mehreren
Hänger gesprungen
Stunden gefunden und da hat man
wieder zurück zum
[Musik]
an dieser Rekonstruktion späten
Aufschluss geben könnte es gar sein dass
es der Täter gar nicht auf das Ehepaar
Siegrist abgesehen hatte sondern auf
seine Besucher
hätte er sonst einen Grund gehabt nach
dem Ehepaar drei weitere Menschen zu
töten es bleiben Fragen
sie Annahme vorhanden aber das
[Musik]
blieb der Polizei nichts anderes übrig
als nach der Waffe und über diese nach
dem Täter zu suchen
Ziele Abdrücken aber reglerufer Ziele
Abdrücke aber Regler und wie gesagt ganz
einfach so klar aber er muss ja gleich
alle agieren
bald glaubte die Polizei eine Spur zu
haben diese führte zu einem nahen
Verwandten namens Adolf
sigristian bereits unsere Bücher
kontrolliert und hekäufer vor deren
geschrieben weil das ist sehr häufig
sehr viele wassersicherheit wo bereits
und unter anderem hätten wir auch die
Rasse vermutlich gesehen kann vor dem
Basler also das ist daher
also der Guss
mehr
ist mir so das ist mir aber
Munition gekauft 100 Schuss Winchester
200 Gramm hätte gekauft
sofort wurde öffentlich dass die Polizei
einen Verdächtigen gefasst hatte
der Fall schien gelöst
doch für Yaki und seine Kollegen war
schnell klar der Verdächtige ein kleiner
Mann von 1,50 m Größe konnte die fünf
Menschen unmöglich alleine überwältigt
und die Toten in der Hütte versteckt
haben
der Sonne versorgen
20 Jahre lang ermittelte die Polizei auf
der Suche nach einem Motiv in alle
Richtungen
ging es um Geld um Außerirdische Affären
aus denen ein Sohn hervorgegangen sein
soll oder doch um eine Abrechnung im
nazi-milieu zu dem Anna westhäuser
Kontakte gepflegt haben soll doch dann
ein Durchbruch
das ist diese Waffe
stolz präsentierte Max Yaki 1996 die
Tatwaffe
in einer Wohnung in Olten wurde sie bei
der Renovation der Küche gefunden
mir hat neue Jahres hat Punkten
die Waffe gehörte einem Mann namens Karl
Doser der scheinbar keine Verbindung zur
Familie Siegrist hatte sofort wurde
international nach ihm gesucht die Waffe
war zusammen mit dosas Pass in der
Wohnung von dosas Mutter gefunden worden
augenfällig seit 1977 also ein Jahr nach
dem Norden fehlte von Karl Doser jede
Spur
der Tag
mindestens sehr sehr auffällig dass
damals
verschwunden ist
ich denke mich
Polizei Winchester Besitzer Karl dosa
aufgesucht und befragt
[Musik]
Verbindungen
und doch fragt sich weshalb bist du so
leicht gelang zu verschwinden ohne dass
dies auffiel wieso konnte oder wollte
niemand Angaben zu seinem Aufenthalt
machen
Kantonspolizei in der Schweiz hat sich
sicher verbessert es wird besser
kommuniziert oder dank der neuen
modernen Kommunikationsmittel aber wir
müssen sagen
die Informationen nicht nur besser
könnte fließen oft wir in Zürich
machen
immer männisch geht einfach hörten in
der Information zwischen der Kanton wo
man nicht so leicht
sicher noch potenzialverhalten für die
interkantonale Zeit verbessern
hat sein Ziel den Mörder von Seven zu
fassen nicht erreicht auch weil niemand
der die Wahrheit kennt aus sagte
inzwischen ist der Fall verjährt
das cardose an der Tat beteiligt war
daran zweifelt Jacke aber nicht was also
wenn heute hier die Tür aufginge und
Dose herein käme
und was wenn alles ganz anders war was
wenn die Gerüchte stimmen das zur
Tatzeit ein kleinwüchsiger Mann am
Tatort gesehen worden sein soll was wenn
die Verbindungen der erschossenen Ana
westhäuser zu den Nazis tatsächlich im
Zusammenhang zum fünffach-mord Stehen
was wenn der verschwundene Doser nicht
mit einem persönlichen Motiv sondern ihm
Auftrag getötet hatte und er danach
nicht freiwillig Flo sondern zum
Verschwinden gebracht wurde
[Musik]
gibt es irgendwo noch jemanden der fast
ein halbes Jahrhundert später die
Antwort auf diese Fragen kennt
[Musik]
wer weiß was wirklich geschah
diese Frage stellt sich auch die
Kantonspolizei Schwyz seit dem 27
februar 2004
am hellichten Tag wird den Altendorf am
Zürichsee die 22-Jährige Patricia
Wilhelm an ihrem Arbeitsplatz in einem
Reisebüro erschossen
[Musik]
die junge Frau aus Einsiedeln wollte
nach Feierabend ihren Vater treffen es
lag ihr etwas auf dem Herzen was das war
konnte sie ihm nie erzählen
[Applaus]
an diesem Tag im Februar hat ein
unbekannter Täter diese junge Frau aus
dem Leben gerissen und bei ihrer Familie
unsädliches Leid hinterlassen in diesem
Film darüber sprechen möchte die Familie
nicht
[Musik]
doch was genau ist damals Ende Februar
Geschehen am Tatort in Altendorf
versucht die Polizei dem Täter oder der
Täterin auf die Spur zu kommen
sie findet zwei Patronenhülsen und zwei
männliche DNA-Spuren es fehlen eine
Geldkassette mit mehreren hundert
Franken Wilhelms Portemonnaie und ihre
Agenda
und vor allem fehlen zeugen
zwischen 15 und 45 und 16:15 Uhr wurde
an der vielbefahrenen Hauptstraße
zweimal auf Patricia Wilhelm geschossen
und niemand will etwas gesehen oder
gehört haben
Stefan Krieger der damals 40-Jährige
Chef der Kriminalpolizei Schwyz erinnert
sich noch genau
wohne ich denn sehr verdienen
in Erinnerung
[Musik]
war damals als Reporter von TeleZüri vor
Ort
sich
Temperaturen es ist bereits dunkel XIV
Patricia wilhelm war allseits beliebt
ihre ehemalige Vorgesetzte doreenka
flisch beschrieb sie als nette
integrierte persons
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht erklärbar am erste was
eigentlich vorstellen
[Musik]
aber ganz sicher stimmt dass die Frau
mit gezielte mit zwei gezielten
untergebracht worden ist und doch eher
noch eine exekutiere
relativ nie hat erwarte nicht Reisebüro
und das macht sie mit einem Optik
relativ unwahrscheinlich dass ein
Roboter
spricht dass die meisten tödlichste
liegt bzw liegt sind wichtig ist dass
man einfach auf dem Rad
verstorben wenn es Beispiel wenn
Personen nicht sehen das bedeutet
oder den langen das für eine Beziehung
im Sinn von des Opfer der
das beobachte ist die Person mit der
zügung
als Bezirk wo ein Ausgangsbasis
die Ermittler gehen davon aus dass ein
Beziehungsdelikt am wahrscheinlichsten
ist die zwei am Tatort gefundene
Patronenhülsen sind auffällig eine
stammt aus dem Jahr 52 aus der
ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei und die
andere aus dem Jahr 56 und war im
Militär in Ex-Jugoslawien verbreitet
wurden ist und genauso alt die Munition
verlängert worden ist
bitte Waffe da hat eigentlich
easy dort war von Analyse gibt dass das
mutmaßlich
zeigt im Verlauf von den mittlere das
ist schon Waffen sie wo in der Ursprung
starte relativ weit verbreitet sich
offizierskreise du dir waffengegeben
Import einfach keine Stadt finden mit
Jugos 19
offene ursprünglich gemeint das auch
abgeglichen regelmäßig übrigens
europaweit und wird einfach
nicht gefunden
[Musik]
die ermittleruntersuchung parallel zur
tatwaffensuche auch die gesicherte DNA
des Tatorts
mehr als 1000 Alibis wurden überprüft
hundert Männer mussten ihre DNA
abgleichen lassen
wenn sie in denen auch Spur Hand ob man
ja auch kein Hit in der Nähe
Datensicherung
mögliches Motiv und so weiter und dann
haben sie mir genau und äh wird wirklich
gemacht haben oder im
angestellkreis vor der Patricia
willhaben nicht Überdehnung führt
der Fall bleibt undurchsichtig niemand
will etwas gesehen oder gehört haben die
Polizei stößt auf Mauern des
Nichtwissens vielleicht auch des
Schweigens drei Verdächtige werden
verhaftet müssen aber mangels Beweisen
wieder freigelassen werden
jemand hat sich
warum die Frau umgebracht wurde ist
nicht im Aussatz des Motive erkennbar
ja und und aufgrund von denen man nicht
schnell tankt das muss irgendwie hier
schwieriger falls sie will ihn
Normalfall ich habe schon viele so
Kriminalfall recherchiert
Gruppenreisen sehr schnell wieder mit
hörte bisschen Früchte da hat man nicht
normales Gericht gehört was könnte sie
und damit den später
sind doch weil der Wirklichkeit mit
Logik allein nur zum Teil beizukommen
ist gingen die Ermittler auch
unkonventionelle Wege wir haben Hypnose
wir haben schließlich und endlich haben
wir auch noch
Medium gesprochen
sehr überrascht sie was ist das Medium
sagen also das hätte Aussage gemacht
oder zum kostenlos
aber mit dem Video wo offensichtlich
keine wirklich so den schläften
eigentlich zum Erfolg führen
eine Belohnung von 5000 Franken wurde
für sachdienliche Hinweise ausgesetzt
ohne Ergebnis
Leiter der Kriminalpolitik die ratlosen
Ermittler versuchten es 2019 mit einem
weiteren effort in der deutschen Sendung
Aktenzeichen XY wandten sie sich an die
breite Öffentlichkeit
der Beweggrund ist sicher zieht es mir
einfach mit der mittagsmethode mit denen
es auch wo wir jetzt zur Verfügung
der 24 februar 2004 Patricia Wilhelm
arbeitet seit knapp vier Wochen im
Reisebüro in Altendorf an diesem Abend
führt sie ein langes Gespräch mit ihrer
Freundin Monika die einen mehr monatigen
Urlaub in Australien verbringt
aber sag mal ich beschäftige dich nur
übrig ja
es geht tatsächlich
[Musik]
doof
mindestens und das
Fokussieren vielleicht auf eine konkrete
Person aber leider mit Information nicht
und trotz allemittlung
auch nach 19 Jahren ist der Fall
Patricia Wilhelm nicht abgeschlossen
die Kantonspolizei Schwyz geht immer
noch jedem Hinweis nach
noch immer hofft sie dass irgendjemand
das Schweigen bricht
es wird es verfolgt haben
macht und weiß wo man richtig denn haben
wir mit dem anderen
es ist zwar unwahrscheinlich so nach
langer Zeit
werden und gleichzeitig gibt
normal
und der geht immer noch Möglichkeit dass
irgendetwas
und das ist versteht nichts der Gründen
zur Polizei es ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich aber es ist möglich dass
sei ein Verbrecher wer die Wahrheit
kennt und sie nicht ausspricht jeder
Ermittler dieser Welt wird dieses Zitat
bestätigen das Schweigen bleibt der
Stille Feind der Wahrheit